à plaisir la galerie des sablons semble
à l'abandon
principalement dans l'allée du fonds au
nombre de magasins ont fermé leurs
portes certaines enseignes ont même dû
rajouter des panneaux dans l'allée
principale pour indiquer leur présence
une rénovation de la galerie se fait
franchement désiré mais le dernier
projet en date est mis en place par le
groupe vastned il y a trois ans n'a
jamais vu le jour
les choses pourraient changer un nouveau
projet est en élaboration
la compagnie de phalsbourg promoteurs en
charge de la rénovation de ce centre
commercial souhaite créer un ensemble
très moderne et futuriste de trente
quatre mille mètres carrés comprenant
une vingtaine de commerces un pôle
restauration et un cinéma
les commerçants de la galerie à qui le
projet a été présenté aussi entre
enthousiasme et crainte
moi je vous restait marqué le conditions
parce qu'il faut ramener giraudeau
revenir sur place et parce qu'on en a le
même place ce qui nous avait dit pour le
moment rien n'est encore fixé
contacté la compagnie de phalsbourg a
indiqué que les conditions de départ ou
de maintien des commerçants seront issus
des négociations individuelles pour les
clients aussi les avis divergent
c'est une très bonne chose vu l'alpha
parc à côté et sont contents qu'un petit
peu plus loin je pense ça peut ramener
des personnes un petit peu plus on va
dire un petit peu plus chic
je trouve que finalement il faudrait
aussi penser au centre ville au petit
commerce
parce que ces grands trucs là comme ça
c'est affolant
donc on s'interroge beaucoup sur ce qui
va être fait avec alpha parc 1 et 2 et
le prochain one nation la zone devrait
effectivement devenir l'eldorado des
centres commerciaux